What if you could see the market before it happens?
Not through a crystal ball, but through high-resolution data.
In the next 4 minutes, I will show you how to stop losing money to
BTC traps and start trading like the top 1 percent
of institutional defenders.
The BTC market is a war zone.
95 percent of retail traders are just 'liquidity' for whales.
You lose because of three things: Information asymmetry, emotional
instability, and noise.
You are bringing a laptop to a supercomputer fight.
It’s time to upgrade your hardware.
Enter Trap Defence BTC.
Our ecosystem is built on three pillars.
First, the Trap Defense Engine.
It detects Whale Dumps and Liquidation Cascades in real-time.
Second, Gemini Visual Storytelling.
We turn dry on-chain data into intuitive news stories you can
understand in seconds.
Third, Dr. Grok.
Our AI psychologist stays by your side 24/7, monitoring your mental
state to prevent revenge trading.
We don't just give you data; we give you a bulletproof mind.
We’ve seen our members survive the most brutal market crashes without
a single liquidation.
This isn't just an academy; it’s a survival protocol.
Our plans start at just 69 dollars, a fraction of
what a single trap could cost you.
The choice is yours: stay in the dark, or see the traps.
Click below to secure your capital.
I am ready when you are.